Monday Monday Monday Monday Monday hey
doing 700 it's Monday Monday Monday and
you're listening to this on Tuesday
Tuesday Tuesday what's good how you
livin how you feeling how you move in oh
we still have two undefeated teams the
NFL Oh in Kansas City was impressive boy
Jared Goff the Rams got it done five oh
no the Eagles are in free fall the
Browns are upsetting Baltimore Sims is
gonna dive into mahomes and Jacksonville
you've watched the film yep very excited
yeah you're gonna dive into Baker in
Baltimore right first big test and I
think he passed I'll find out more what
else did you get into the Eagles and
Vikings you watch the Eagles I did
everyone's freaking out about the
offense and what else you get into no
that was it I mean that mean the Browns
Ravens game took four hours so I don't
know why because it went to five
quarters yeah thanks for that thriller
you put on my dot radar there someone so
Matt one of the producers for the show
goes I mean I tried a newsreel all the
games and there's only ten minute clips
online it takes too long and I go
think about what Sims has to do yeah
like each one's an hour and a half two
hours that's why the new cool thing is
saying you watch the film right if you
really watch the film you would have no
time for anything else
because that's your life that is my life
yeah by the way we have an SL FL Sims I
love go trade announcement team Odell
Rogers made a move and right now it's
looking pretty darn good I engineered a
trade hold on I got to figure out who
what did you do to get oh gee spleen
buster some people in the league think
that I that I convinced him I think it
was pretty fair right
we gave up feelin Devonta Freeman
latavius Murray and Payton barber mm-hmm
and we got back Tyreke Hill Aaron
Rodgers Tariq Cohen and Crowder meaning
that on our fantasy team what I mean who
is this guy you we've robbed him oh gee
spleen biology I don't like saying that
I don't want to gloat I think that I
think if Devonta Freeman ends up being
what we all think he could be if he
could be healthy and Thielen he may have
the two best players in the trade you
have feelings you know the first wide
receiver at
in the history of the NFL to start five
games not gonna die out at all but
Avante Freeman's 50/50 but I want to say
officially goodbye to Adam Thielen
right it's been amazing to have him it's
really it's like what a fantasy football
he's a lock every week but now for our
podcast fantasy team right to have Aaron
Rodgers and Beckham first of all our T
name is Odell Raj yes that's fitting we
have those two Tyree kill who we love
yes tarik Cohen who I cannot wait for
you guys to see what we did with him on
our show this week Wednesday show I'm
just gonna say Tariq oh and we've called
him the mensch we've called him the
Mitzvah we've called him everything we
gave him a Bar Mitzvah inside of a
Jewish delicatessen on 38th Street
you're smiling right now because it was
that much it was it was awesome I'm
actually smiling that because I think
the people that do the show they get mad
at you for opening your big mouth no
it's this is promotion check it out
Wednesday a p.m. YouTube's lovekins
gonna be great and by the way you know
else we have on our fantasy team but
person Blake bortles oh great and Sims
has decided you did it very angrily in a
text message that we will have Blake
bortles on our fantasy team and he will
be on the bench every single game so
even when Rodgers has a body it was bad
karma for our team yeah I felt like it
was bad karma and we decided to play
Rogers they got us 43 points and they
have won us the week we need like six
points out of Chris Thompson tonight I
feel good the thick points out of Chris
Township yeah we should get that easy
perfect easy
so bortles on the bench also Golden Tate
responded to a tweet of ours really yes
so Fenric put out the video where we
asked should the Jets fire top will the
Jets fire troubles that they lose and
Golden Tate responded with no they
should fire The OC with a trash can
emoji Wow
like I feel like that should be news
somewhere but Golden Tate responded I
wonder why does he loves us I know but
why why would he just go after the OC
and then I thought okay Lions play Jets
first game of the year Donald was dicing
them up right yeah I don't know hey Matt
the OC
okay
yeah Golden Tate might be coming out
coming to hang with us here soon do I
have to hang it will figure it out I'll
ask him we'll ask him Oh
other big thing this weekend Saturday
hook up huh
what one what does it feel like when
Texas beats Oklahoma oh it's amazing
it's always a special day I mean it's
it's something that when I wake up I'm
always like ah okay
Texas Oklahoma today how do you feel uh
I just I always brings me back to what
it felt like to be playing in that game
what it feels like to be driving through
a bus at the Texas State Fair and seeing
all the Texas fans that are doing this
and then the oh you fans are either
doing this or giving the middle finger
all together right so it's Texas or yeah
horns were down horns down is usually
their thing right yeah it's a cool I
would really suggest suggest that for
anybody bucket list if you have a
weekend off in early October the Red
River Rivalry or showdown whatever the
hell it is [ __ ] out yeah it used to be
the shootout it's a phenomenal
experience and it's it's truly one of
the cooler sporting sporting events
there is this happened on Saturday
[Applause]
and then he throws it he's wearing this
big t-shirt and he's so cute yeah did
you watch that life I did not watch it
live I had the game on live I was kind
of just moving around the house and then
I was walking back down into the family
room I looked at my phone at all these
text messages I saw the video so then I
rewound it because I was taping it
because I knew I was enough to leave at
some point for my little brother I mean
my little boys flag football game yeah
I didn't get to see much of the second
half I was kind of watching oh yeah I
know it was I'm done so but I did it
blow it did yes
yeah it was really cool like I said like
I told you I almost cried it was a
pretty special moment it really is they
just know that you had an impact like
that is always cool it really is two
year old kids I don't go and I'm Kris
right it's crazy it's crazy gets me
emotional right now I know I'm like how
emotional like why does it make you
emotional I don't know I guess it just
always feels good to be liked to be
appreciated to a degree to show that
there was you know somebody growing up
that did appreciate me even though he
probably didn't know what the hell was
his parents were probably telling them
hey you're blonde there you like
quarterback did you like to throw it
yeah but I guess I think it's cool
because I know I was that kid once too
you know are you saying I mean whether
it was I'm feel sick yeah well there was
Phil early on or denim with the John
Elway and Troy Aikman right so I get
where he's coming from
yeah to think about that yeah everyone
always says pretend you're in the
backyard and you're Michael Jordan
you're Derek Jeter right and some kid is
going to everyone going I'm Chris soon I
know man I know it was cool it's cool it
really was so if you have a two-year-old
that interrupts people take a video
I'm Adam left Co and send it and I'd
like to know that feeling but I thought
the other part that I really liked was
Gus Johnson you got a you got a ha ha at
Augusta onsen
[Applause]
two years old said he was going to be
Chris the kid played great they did he's
a baller he's a baller I love college
quarterbacks that are not afraid of
content right and just throw themselves
in there he's thick as hell i DM him
from the sims and left go account dude
you play great with kick-ass he was like
thanks man
and I was like he definitely thinks it
Sims if only he knew that Sims doesn't
understand oh that's cool Sims as
they're appreciating it was awesome I'm
so glad they won I mean again I don't
think Texas back is like a national
contender yet were they 505 and one
after that week one lost to Maryland in
Maryland so yeah things are on the
up-and-up and the one thing I could say
about the team is you know they play
hard they do have some speed especially
on defense so that's what's cool but men
Oklahoma Kyler murder I know I mean I
want him to play football but I don't
want him to get hurt and I know there's
guaranteed money in baseball but the
speed when he hits the edge it's special
people look like theirs they're walking
how fast he's me yeah III mean he's an
NFL quarterback you know I don't care
that he's 511 I mean he was your son
though would you and you knew that he
was like a first-round pick in MLB you
tell him to play baseball probably yes
yeah yeah I would I mean it's it's a
longer career it's more about yourself
instead of having to you know worry
about others around you you like I've
always said you could be the greatest
football player in the world and you get
stuck with the bad coaching staff and a
bad team around you nobody will ever
know baseball okay yeah might think that
you get stuck on a bad team everybody
but you know everyone's gonna see oh he
batted for 330 and you know your [ __ ]
hits 40 home runs and you know through
20 people out at the plate from
centerfield or whatever it is so there's
that you can stand out on an individual
basis a lot of good games we're gonna
dive into your film notebook but I think
the topic of the day and it feels at the
topic in the last two days is our guy
yeah Odell Beckham
and the comments that were made right I
did not watch you on TV this morning so
I do not need opinions good but I'm just
gonna play you
clip this is Odell with Joe Cena
Anderson sitting next to Lil Wayne and
this was recorded Tuesday I asked you
before
maybe this was recorded a few weeks ago
and you talked to some people and you're
like no this was a hundred percent
recorded this week Tuesday in New York
City and the Giants had no idea no idea
which is funny because when we book
people for the show right there's two
ways there's a you either go through
their people where you go through the
team right and whenever you go through
the team the team could say no it's an
extra person that could say no so Joe
Cena
I guess look if I'm O'Dell yeah and
you're like hey we're gonna do an
interview with you and Lil Wayne yeah
I'd be like holy [ __ ] this is amazing is
my off day I could do it if I was
exactly right you have problem with that
I have no problem with that okay I don't
know hey these are grown man he's a
grown man
as and Shermer said yeah and he has a
relationship with Joe Cena obviously you
know professionally texting whatever it
may be and yes he obliged these you know
whatever the outcome or this interview
in general yeah new must have known
little Wayne was in town but this is why
we've said it anybody's listen to us Joe
Cena Anderson yeah is an NFL insider let
me just say when Joe Cena Anderson says
I'm hearing or this that blah blah blah
I'm telling you listen I've been around
her she covered me when I was with the
Denver Broncos she really she works hard
she makes relationships within the
building
she's the players report she is she's
the point Mo's more times than not I
would say yes her connections do come
from the players shefter is the owner
right Rapoport is the coaches Joe Cena's
the players I mean it's very I don't
think it's a hundred percent across the
board like that but yeah yeah general
breakdown you're right exactly right
alright so here is Odell talking about
Elon first of all ok
I mean we're delay what was the Odell
Pike what was this Odell talking voice
just cuz a little Wayne talked one way
did he think he had I like talk like him
to alright let's listen to see if he
talked weird
I don't know like I said I feel like
he's not gonna get out the party he's
not you know he lies not running but is
it a matter of time as you can can you
still do it yeah it's been pretty safe
it's been you know cool catching a
shadow and trying to take it to the
house but I'm you know I wanna I wanna
go over the top of somebody which we've
always said and then there's another one
more point like in the past five years
they found a way to run a cover to keep
everything in front and I said I play me
and there's no there's no way to how do
we beat this I feel like I'm being out
schemed and then I also don't have a
chance to like do something I got to
take a slant Gore safety which is what
we've always said yes I'm gonna let you
go first
right what was your take on all of this
it's been a blow up like people are it
is he's getting the full you're a bad
guy treatment is the crimson now is he
as bad as Antonio Brown this is just
well I'm gonna take it back I'm just
gonna take it back there because he
hasn't threatened to beat anybody up in
the media or done some of the action but
but he's a bad guy I didn't hear any of
this so though Antonio Brown a few weeks
ago which was actually warranted the bad
guy for like label on him there and I
don't really think Antonio Browns a bad
guy but he's had some actions where I'd
go that warns that label if you do crap
like that you people are gonna call you
a bad guy when you say we're gonna see
how your jaw is and stuff like that now
like my first thing is why why why Odell
you've worked so hard this offseason to
restructure your reputation in the New
York area I guess that's where I first
go okay hey I know it's Tuesday and it's
little Wayne and that's special and damn
I'd probably show up for that interview
too right yes yeah I got no issue with
the interview in general but to not
think that those questions were coming
after it's been the main topic of
discussion here in the New York City
area for the first three four weeks of
the season and not have better answers
available and you know what I know he's
being honest there's just time when
but I'll take you back to an old segment
on Dave Chappelle when keeping it real
goes wrong okay that's a very good
throat thank you
and that's what happened here yes he
kept it real but you know when you're
the leader of a locker room and such a
polarizing figure like that no one cares
everyone's gonna look at you like you're
pointing your you're placing blame
you're pointing fingers you're you're
you know talking about somebody who's
not in the room there to defend
themselves and that's where it's just
it's a bad look I don't think it's the
worst thing he's ever done or will ever
do but you know for a team that's won in
three or going into the game yeah
they're yesterday were going into one
and three this was not the kind of talk
that they needed to build the team or
build camaraderie off of that so you're
saying what I've been hearing all
morning yeah that Odell Beckham jr. was
too honest that it's bad leadership that
there's some things that you can't say
that just because it's true doesn't mean
it's the right thing to say I would say
that because of that the Giants the
Giants have been avoiding the truth for
years yes they have I'm gonna go in a
little bit of a rant yeah go ahead
instead of addressing these things and
dealing with these things nobody talks
about it
omission is weakness omission is
deception omission is lying and I think
it's time that we stop lying
Eli is a liability you know what happens
when there's a problem but you avoid it
and no one feels comfortable enough to
voice their frustrations people explode
how do they explode oh I don't know like
sterling Shepard punching a bench and
slamming a trashcan because Eli threw an
interception when he was wide open on
the bottom of the screen on a possible
screen pass
that's him exploding what Odell is doing
in my opinion is releasing the pressure
right somebody had to go we have a
problem in the public cuz you know I'm
not hearing from the public ever Eli
yeah like when have I seen Eli on
television at all the last month I don't
and
people would argue that's good
leadership you want but you want
leadership a good sorry the fellow of
ethics at Harvard Business School
his name is Bill George I'd say it's
like the leader of leadership right yeah
he is a quote be transparent with your
team even when the truth may be
unpopular or inconvenient this should be
behind closed doors left go this should
be done in private the Giants have been
whispering in private about Eli for
years but take it to your manager follow
the chain of command I know a lot of
people out there have had managers that
refuse to acknowledge the problem they
sit back and then they end up just
complaining with your coworkers Aaron
Rodgers calls out his head coach and his
playmaker and we go that'll get changed
that'll get things done everything Odell
said was accurate we just don't like the
messenger we don't like that he's
sitting next to little Wayne when he
said it
maybe these public comments maybe can
push Eli to not fall at the first sight
of pressure maybe it'll push him
maybe these public comments will make
Eli uncomfortable because maybe he needs
to risk more all I know is as an Eagles
fan I know it all too well
2008 and 2012 mm-hmm Tom Coughlin went
out publicly and put pressure on
everybody and what happened those two
years they talked about 2007 and 2011
they may wonder all right okay yeah so
when they got called out publicly
I think Odell is trying to be a leader I
think he's trying to create Pratt
passion I think the problem is is that
we're choosing not to listen to him
because he's not doing it the way that's
been done and I'm here to tell you that
how it's been done has Eli three years
into having should have been retired as
his quarterback for the next few years
that's the problem I mean I I don't
disagree with you with what you're
saying I hear you I mean I'm not I'm
just saying it was on it was unnecessary
the way there was better ways he could
have done it he didn't have to say it
even the way he said it he could have
said in other ways where I think the
same thing would have got across the
piece
so are you saying he should have done it
in a closed-door meeting words yeah even
though he actually used like what didn't
you like him you know I just think he
could have been he said he said I feel
like I'm being out skiing right everyone
knows how to defend me right in essence
like I don't get moved around I'm not in
motion I see even what they do with
Julio or Antonio Brown on the bunch set
or anything like that but he was doing
that this first few weeks and then he
goes you know they're lying me on to do
a slant and then I have to take it sixty
yeah I know I understand this
frustration he got a bomb from Eli this
weekend iiiiii coincidence yeah no I
mean I don't know I hope not I hope it's
the fact that their whole team an
organization looked at it and said we
have issues we have to start taking
shots down the field in general I mean
they knew they had to have big plays or
they wouldn't had a wide receiver pass
back to the sake well Berkeley in it
they obviously knew that was an issue
going into the game when Odell my fake
se hit yeah and then also throws the
longest touchdown of the season for the
Giants yes so stands in pressure where
the actual quarterback wouldn't do right
and then throws the longest touchdown of
the season it's such a much it's such a
like a reflection of what's happening
there and the issues in it is it's a
what is it ironic don't you think I'll
only do think Jets Broncos [ __ ] I don't
necessarily hate what he said I hate it
for him that's what I am I don't he
doesn't need this negative connotation
by his name now where it all gets fueled
again as he's this you know just loose
cannon who does whatever and you know
part of being the highest-paid guy or
one of those naughty lies the high I got
you I got you but being one of those
guys in the face of the franchise is to
you know help the team flourish in the
right way and I don't know if that's the
right way okay I know this I know he's
totally right about everything he said I
also know Eli didn't call him out on the
boat trip week though okay so I mean if
we're gonna go like apples to apples I
know Eli could have been my cruisers hey
you [ __ ] guys didn't go to the M
dropped all these pass
and I threw him on the money I might
have been [ __ ] the rest of the year
but that day I was good and you guys
[ __ ] it up yeah so again I think
there's got to be some respect there
towards that and I mean to your point
where we don't hear from you lie yes
this is part of the problem we don't
hear from you lie because the the Eli
the Manning mafia is fighting the fight
for him behind this behind the scenes
exactly right there's always an excuse
the Mannings are great with the media
they have a incredible outreach
I mean we've know Peyton's been famous
through his career for after a bad game
calling people and members of the media
and telling them the real story of what
really happened and I mean everybody
knows that in football so so I applaud
odo so I get it I understand you
appreciating it I'm just saying from a
from an actual someone that's been in a
locker room perspective yes there's
gonna be guys in there they're gonna be
like
glad he said that somebody had to say it
I'm sure I think even the fact that like
Landon Collins came out and said well
yours read with it but there's also
gonna be like 10 to 15 other guys you're
gonna go that's [ __ ] and you have to
remember them - you didn't say sure
Mercer was pissed I get it of course the
Schirmer can't be losing the line from
five weeks in and he knows he's wrong
for one reason tell me why Hodel knows
he's wrong he called a team meeting on
Saturday night because he knew this [ __ ]
was about to hit the fast he did so he
knew damn I might have overstepped here
a little bit I've done that a lie is
what I apologized I you know I love
O'Dell and I really just didn't wanted
to do this for Odell yeah you're not
upset with him you're just like damn it
man now you got to deal with the exactly
right I will say this though as a root
as a fan of the Eagles there was a
quarterback wide receiver issue that
defined a good five-year stretch of that
franchise yeah Donovan McNabb versus T
oh and what it was was half the locker
room like tio would call out Donovan and
didn't think he was the best leader and
didn't think it was right and the
defense got pissed and Donovan always
took quote/unquote the high road yeah I
don't think staying quiet and not
defending yourself and not arguing with
somebody or like addressing it
always the high road sometimes I think
it's the passive-aggressive road yes so
I saw that happen to the Eagles where
all of the best players on the team
still side with Terrell oh yeah I know I
know and I think the fact that it never
got out there it just bubbles it becomes
this rivalry where you pass each other
in the hallway and it gets worse and
worse and worse and the best thing you
could do is talk about it now if this
can lead to good conversations if Eli
can come out there and maybe going for
the team make listen I haven't been that
great I haven't been that good and maybe
he did that I just know that when when
the other 52 guys on the team are going
were one in four and the big issue right
now is the highest-paid player on our
team is making the least amount of plays
I know it's awkward I know it's annoying
but somebody needs to freaking say it
yeah just get it out because then maybe
he can laugh about it he can own it but
if everyone's whispering about it it
just gets worse it does and worse yeah
so maybe this was the release because
that sterling reaction there's no reason
he should be that upset about an
interception that wasn't even to him no
I am I don't know exactly what he was
frustrated at but I watched these open I
know exactly right so only thing he's
open and Eli throws it off his back
throws a fade away a fade away floater
Hawaii threw it like that either where
Mike Adams just jumps in yeah and and I
get it I just I'm hoping for the Giants
sake I'm just hoping it doesn't help
them for Thursday because the Eagles
themselves are going through some [ __ ]
or apparently Jay Ajay is coming out
nothing like a running batter and he'd
say he came out I can't believe we
abandoned in the run maybe cuz you
fumbled inside the 10 maybe maybe we
abandon the run cuz you have a fumbling
problem and that Wendel Smallwood is is
better than you right now like it's not
even close it's funny you're saying that
I mean my big thing with the take away
of the game is like Jaya is just ain't
the same guy no he's one leg it's you
guys are leaving yards out there right
now with him around the ball I mean it's
Cory Clement Wendel small wouldn't
clinical not gets back that is your
backfield they need them yeah I mean
they really need a notch above all of
them and I think I mean they really do
that's what you're missing in your
football team for the way your team
blocks
the line of scrimmage at times in the
run game you guys get the bare minimum
out of it you know that's how we always
talk about the great running backs
there's eight yards to be there what are
you gonna make out of those I guess five
I mean he gets yes exactly right well
there's eight this well how small would
can get 15 20 some time away
I put small wooden or Fantasyland up and
got a six good job well who'd you rip
off for that one and you know that was
just off the waiver wire I think we'll
get into that highlight in a sec yeah
before we get into the plays I just got
one more big kind of news thing Rams
fourth quarter on their own 42 McVeigh
goes further on fourth and one and wins
the game mm-hmm Cowboys on their
opponents 42 in overtime fourth and one
Garrett punts loses the game right we
just watched the Eagles laugh at
conventional football last year and show
that aggressively going for it on fourth
down is that is a difference maker yeah
I'm gonna read two quotes one for
McVeigh one from Garrett after the game
you tell me which one you like McVeigh
our offensive lineman had the confidence
to be able to get those six inches we
attack success we don't fear failure we
want to go for the win in that situation
getting six inches to close out was
something that we felt the percentages
were in our favor
Garrett it was a long one yard I know we
both love Jason Garrett yeah what a
great human good guy the reason he's
lasted there so long with JT with Jerry
Jones as Jerry knows what he's putting
him through and Jason is a strong man in
the locker room I know that he gets made
fun of a lot but he always keeps it
tight always keeps it organized Jason
players love him because he holds
everyone accountable he holds himself
accountable Jerry Jones afterwards we
were being outplayed it was time for
risks at that time yeah dak Prescott I
mean I would have gone for it but I
don't question the coach's decision yeah
those two situations yeah I think show
you the issues with Jason Garrett and
why Shawn McVeigh is great yeah but what
situation is Jason Garrett I'm not gonna
sit here and have
guess whether or not he should be fired
because I don't think he should be fired
right now no not right that was for
Jerry Jones to come out and say that
it's a like I know he was on the husband
going into the other day that was a shot
across the bow that was like a red flare
to go like you [ __ ] that up and we're
keeping tally now run out yes yeah I
mean McVeigh mcveigh's new school
Garrett's old school okay and the new
school is like what you're saying I mean
it's about being aggressive down the the
league has changed from the days of
Jason Garrett playing in his early days
of coaches to Jeff Fisher's it's an
awful how many I mean how many the it's
the offensive world now I mean to drive
down the field with two minutes and 80
yards it's it's big whoopty [ __ ] deal
now with the way the defenses are called
throw the ball the triple coverage pass
interference oh he touched my ear as I
was throwing the ball another 15 yards
so just think that your defense is just
gonna make stop after stop after stop
with the passing League NFL and the way
the rules are you have to that has to
come into play you have to think I can't
give the ball back to Russell Wilson or
deshaun Watson yes and the Cowboys were
being outplayed I mean come on the the
Texans outplayed them really the whole
night they moved the ball kind of up and
down the field and just screwed up
little situations here and there the
Cowboys scored on one because they got a
fumble recovery and it gave him a short
field a touchdown right and then their
field goal drive to tie it took dak
Prescott breaking three sacks making
crossbody 145 yards you were already at
their 42 and the big issue you bought
mentioned the first thing you said when
you came in the amount of money that you
spent on the offensive line taking dak
taking Zeke with the fourth pick in the
draft right you do all of that for that
month that's exactly right
for that moment we always talk about
where's the money on your football team
and is it performing that's a huge thing
it's you know can't connect the dots oh
they have dirt they got a 70 million
dollar offensive line and they're not
running it well well then there's an
issue with what you've paid and how you
spread your team out but yes that that's
why they've drafted Zack Martin and they
got our guy you know Smith that left
tackle
Tyron smithing they drafted Connor
Williams in the second round and they
took a chance with Lyle collar boy to
that payoff right was amazing so and
then you dropped Ezekiel Elliott yes
that is the situation right there you go
okay
if we lose and don't get it I went down
with our best part of our team I went
down swinging we throw the right
uppercut and I threw the right uppercut
and we didn't make it and that's that to
me is how you can go away from a game
never feeling happy you lost but when
you lose doing what you do best it's
easier to swallow right and it's like
the Colts when they went for we're going
for the win right my issue is is you pun
it with like 2:30 left you what do you
want the tie because you're not getting
the ball back you ain't driving back
down again
Shawn McVeigh and the Rams Gurley is
reaching another level yeah he's the
best running back in football there's
just no denying that right I mean we
because not anything we've been saying
it all year but I hopefully everybody
now is watching and going okay yup he's
pretty awesome
I think everyone kind of knows that I
mean he was like a first pick in the
draft and for a lot of fantasy drafts
yeah I will say this though if you
really look there's something brewing
that I I think I'd like to address on
Wednesdays pod yeah the last three games
for the Rams right they've scored 35 38
and 33 boom baby they're clicking right
defense has allowed 23 31 31
right who'd they play let's the chargers
Viking Seahawks yeah that's right and
really what interests me is the Vikings
and Seahawks both of their D line o
lines stay right so I know that Peters
that Talib is out yeah um but I was
watching a show today and they're
talking about the Rams and one of the
best defense of the NFL I don't think
they do no they don't but they have
playmakers that will be able to change
pace as a game especially when things
get a little tighter against quality
football teams this is the thing I think
you have to remember with the Rams
defense a little and it's not playing
great and I will dive into that film
letting up way too many big plays in the
past game which I don't understand and
and I'll break this down more but this
is the other thing I think you have to
take into account the locket burned
Peters right week before Thielen and
Diggs were getting a baldric Robins
exactly right so and Wade Phillips can
be a
recive that way he can he just he's not
always gonna sit back and play Ben don't
break oh we held you to a field well
first of all like we talked about it's
better for the right side better for the
team this is the way to go
this is we don't want to let the other
teams offense doing a 12-play drive and
then we don't we're sitting over in the
sidelines no their money you know they
got a lot of big playmakers and money is
done often since out of the ball they
want to do that go ahead I was just
gonna say Sunday night yeah New England
Kansas City right you ready for New
England a pound the rock because that's
what's gonna happen
yeah oh good that's what we're gonna
witness right we're gonna watch Soni
Michele pound in the rock and mahomes on
the sideline for eight minutes at a time
yeah well that's how you gotta beat the
Rams and Chiefs I I guess you ain't
gonna out score room III will see with
New England I don't know because no
angle we might say screw you we think we
can execute ten play passing drives and
go down to score touchdowns well there
are different animals for this game
could be like 16 I mean who knows what
it could be but I think this is the
other thing we have to take into account
with the Rams right now and just their
defense aside especially people go into
the game going we can't stop their
offense so they're willing to try and
push the envelope on the offensive side
more than they really normally would so
don't forget that aspect of it where
they go man we don't really like getting
in these formations and taking these
shots but our head coach is kind of told
us our defense doesn't match up well
with their offense and we might have to
push the envelope and get out so they're
the other teams are going into the game
going where's our shots where's our big
plays there's more of an emphasis on it
than other weeks and that does play into
it at times man I'm excited Rams are in
the middle of a road trip they're going
the Broncos next and Broncos are gonna
be pissed yes at home it should be
interesting all right let's get into the
film notebook the game of the year of
the week was a little disappointing
Kansas City Jacksonville I wrote down
the first note that I have as I was
watching the game mahomes rolling out
super successful
I've never seen an offense attack the
defense like this yeah I've never seen
Jacksonville's defense look like they
were trying to contain somebody right
usually their attack yes film yeah what
popped out just from that side of the
ball yeah I mean just from that side of
the ball I mean
first of all I think the the plan of
attack right away from the game was get
Jacksonville going horizontally and if
you go back and watch the start of the
football game the first play of the game
was a speed Suites tie read kill and
then it was a screen out to the side
they did all these plays to kind of go
okay you want to play this eight-man
front well we're gonna spread you out in
that eight-man front and make you get
wide and have to think sideline to
sideline and then they would have there
an occasional you know up the middle run
or an aggressive pass in between those
holes that they have just spread it I
feel like Kareem hunts the perfect
running back for that office yes because
everything else is kind of finesse in
speed yeah and he's brute strength brute
strength and even in the run game they
did things where you know what I would
call like it's like a it's like a Ben
scheme so they might run inside zone to
the left and the tight end comes along
the backside okay kicks out the backside
DN for the cutback but also takes away
the aggressiveness of the defense
because the defense goes wait are they
gonna run the bootleg and the tight ends
gonna come out the backdoor right so
they did all these little things to take
away the aggression of Jacksonville
right oh but right off the bat is Andy's
different offense different this year
than it's been in the past I don't think
so I don't think it's any different I
mean may a few you little bells and
whistles you want me to go throw it or
do you want to go ahead if you want to
go through it yeah I'm gonna see if I
can there's a few lapels and whistles
the big difference is it's just gonna
look different because you got a [ __ ]
guy that can throw the ball over the
Colorado Rockies and that's the
difference first of all first driving
game yeah the first drive of the game
like these are little things that get
lost in the shuffle in a game like this
rolling - you're right throwing a 15
yard out route to the full-back Sherman
as he's tightly covered on a on a what
was that a third in one like dozer plays
Jacksonville usually wins and then go we
punted it out and they went down on a
long drive drive and now we're playing
their game but since he's so talented
and he makes little throws like that
they get lost in the context of the game
sometimes those are huge plays and a
defensive football game when you're
playing like Jacqueline would play in
the Jacksonville Jaguars you wrote
little surprised how soft Jags are
playing covers yes I was I just
my overall theme at the very end and you
continue to read is I think Jacksonville
almost disrespected themselves to a
degree yeah I do I don't I think they
under valued their own talent in this
football game I think the next time they
play them they're gonna go we were a
little too nice and gave them too much
respect how can you be too nice it's
just the the some of the just think
about some of the throws throughout the
game just easy six yard hitch routes to
the sides like Jacksonville just given
up five and six yard what do they
normally do usually he's in your face to
scare you and then backs out right at
the line of scrimmage you know and think
I mean right at the snap or what it
already stays in there but the Tyreke
Hill factor is real and it backed them
to hell off and it made them play more
to safety defenses than I can ever and
they played more to safety defenses in
the first two drives of the game than
they I feel like they have in in full
court at full four quarter games and
when you say a team plays two safeties
they're worried about the deep they were
worried about their typically on one
safety and everyone kind of matches up
and plays their zone yeah but Jackson so
you're telling me Jacksonville did not
do the Seattle scheming they they did
the Seattle scheme but when they did it
he was they were very far off I mean he
was eight and ten yards off at times and
you know I think the big thing is to
Kansas City's pass protection was
phenomenal I thought that is one part
that I will say surprise me freaking
Randy freaking Reed now yeah he gets
them going they don't know what to think
he had a little play-action fake with
everything to make Jacksonville he
stopped for a step but uh I mean his
protection throughout the day was pretty
pretty phenomenal you even wrote yeah
Reed stayed patient with the rain stayed
patient patient would the run when he
had a lead so I kind of get it yes but I
mean there's been times even honor the
first few drives when the game was seven
nothing and ten nothing and thirteen
nothing I just said okay yeah he ran it
up the middle on second and second and
eight and made it third and six who
cares it's the fact that he ran it that
they have to sit there and it gives more
you know viably viability to their play
actually vibhut gave me a believability
is what I'm gonna say
mahomes just him as a whole or after the
game you were like this is gonna be a
big
test this is not the Denver Broncos he's
gonna get on the field his eyes gonna
get wide he's yeah holy crap right where
do you feel about him now I am he's the
man I just was my last question
yesterday was just to see how he reacted
did he get frazzled by that in the rain
I mean he just couldn't have seemed he
couldn't see couldn't have been more
comfortable
I mean flustered was Monday night and
that was not that flustered so at home
in the rain which I do think helps
Kansas City because they're not the
faster team and the more physical team
and that's slow Jacksonville down a
little bit but yeah I just again have
amazed with just some of the passes he
makes the ability to hang in the pocket
the ability when nothing's there to
throw a ball and be safe with it but
still kind of give his guy a chance like
Romo ever mentioned at the one time like
he was in the end zone you said he spice
it up he rolls laughing avoid sandal
it's there's a swarm of Jaguars and he
just stops bounces looks left looks
right and ghost now I got nothing and
throws it away but like to stop and find
a pocket like 15 yards away from where
you started I mean like Case Keenum
would have [ __ ] in his pants yeah
and then throw the ball across the field
into a safe place where maybe his naked
eye catches it he's a little insane
complete Chiefs offense yeah
Jacksonville defense ok hasn't been as
dominating this year as last year right
will that change do you think I don't
think it's I don't think it's gonna be
as dominant as last year now they've
played some teams that have some
experience with them you know I mean
they got it they got the Patriots ooh
right they know what they're about the
Tennessee Titans okay but I still hold
down the ninth I think they'd um I mean
you look at it it's 15 it's 20 it's 9
its 12 and then yesterday was 30 yeah
and then also bortles threw a pick to a
defensive lineman so that's 23 and were
there any other ones no no but I mean he
you know he put them in some tough spots
yeah you know what he let up and the
other
feel where you get sack fumble Danika
they got a short drive to kick a field
to go up dirt this is how close the NFL
is I bore dolls yeah they had the ball
on the one and they go for they don't
get it yeah so that's seven price and
then he throws it off a guards head and
he gets picked off in the endzone that's
14 could've been 20 to 14 at halftime
this game is one of the things I mean
this this will be a nail-biter when they
play each other again when Leonard
fournette back in there and not him not
having him yesterday not having Cory
grant those are big injuries for their
football team you know again I mean I
would argue Leonard for nets the best
player they have on the offensive side
of the ball so they didn't have him you
know that's that's a game-changing
moment but I just thought overall the
game plan by Kansas City I mean yeah
Ethan think of Andy the second drive
they did the third down he calls the
screen pass it was like say it was third
and nine he throws a screen pass out to
cream hunt first down little plays like
that where he had a good feel that they
might do something pressure wise his his
game planning and film watching and he
goes you know what dial dial up a third
nine screen on the Jacksonville Jaguars
come on man that's that's awesome that's
awesome game planning um I wrote yeah
little surprised how soft the Jags are
planning yeah we were I already went
through yesterday I know my question now
is yeah bortles yeah man yeah we didn't
talk Tyree Jalen Ramsey okay
talk about that was that was interesting
and Tyreke scary I mean we know that and
Jalen Ramsey was scared shitless of him
early in the game like why I mean like
he was playing off and his hips were
turned and faster than I've ever seen
them turned he was just gobble early
right he's like if you're gonna run I'm
running right but you wanna go you want
to go but then the game got go and he
got in a few man-to-man situations he
jammed the [ __ ] out of him a few times
wrote him out the sidelines let him know
about it you know there was a few other
instances where Tyreke was open down the
field like we talked about with mahomes
every week there was about two or three
plays in this game where I go ooh he
just has to be more aware that ty reeks
one-on-one outside and it doesn't look
like he's open yet
but you just gotta launch it he's gonna
run by everybody you have Pete Eric's on
our fantasy team I am very happy I am
but I thought about that man I will say
with that
chun-tae Reid gets him down the left
sideline and the go-round later on that
rat was all over so it was awesome there
was the other hitched route where Jalen
was playing off you got about another
eight or ten yards on them um I just
think next time around that Jacksonville
has to take more chances on that side of
the ball they have to just go you know
what we're gonna get up in your face
we're not gonna let you have six yard
completion you might beat us but we're
gonna go down I mean you didn't drive
Jalen Ramsey in the top ten for nothing
at some point you got to just go hey we
got to put him out there so Jacksonville
it sounds like from your notes played
off and said let's keep it in front of
us they're only gonna beat us if they at
the bottom yeah right and instead they
got matriculated down the field then
they would turn the ball over to bortles
and they couldn't do it no exactly right
and not that they couldn't do anything
they moved the ball to but you know
Jacksonville got in a game that they're
not comfortable with but just that we
got to depend on Blake bortles to throw
the ball and you know hey did he have a
few throws here and there yes but damn
he had a heart and a lot of horrible
ones I mean damn II threw some ducks out
there you know and some of them people
go and he dropped that well yeah they
dropped them because it was going
sideways helicopter I mean people are
gonna drop those kind of throws in the
rain so again don't just look at it and
go oh well he got a little lucky with
some drought how did he throw that off
the guards heads so okay he was getting
under pressure he you know I'll change
what I thought I thought he was trying
to throw it to his left and the ball
just slipped out of his hand
I think after watching it on film he
wanted the throw to Yeldon over the
middle and as he's getting pressure and
he's starting his motion I think he
realized oh crap he's gonna be covered
and I might throw a pick and I honestly
think he was trying to throw it down on
the ground at his feet but he had too
many people around to try to do that
maneuver and it went off AJ cans head
and bounced in the air and interception
yeah I know that was that was a huge
play how do you explain the Chris Jones
touchdown throw there could that mean
there's no explanation I mean he threw
it to him I have the explanation is 7 0
as in 70 thank you oh he's back no he's
not back but damn that's that's the [ __ ]
well hold on if we're gonna make him in
the 30s where is he now I
but 54 I'm not gonna drop them that far
Oh 40s it may be somewhere I don't know
what are you yeah we gonna make me rank
them every week now you were gonna call
me somebody no I was nothing really nice
of you to do that on camera no no it was
that was gonna say it was you think I
was gonna say what am i Florio but okay
so that was that okay oh but anything
else we'll do it now let me I'm reading
through hold on yeah I guess anything
else about the Jacksonville offense
Kansas City defense is this Jacksonville
good or is Kansas City's defense maybe a
little bit better than we thought they
came in like 30 to either their third
thing to is they have playmakers too
they have at least they have that maybe
guys that we don't know about because
this is not our Eric Berry or Derrick
John's no the deep floors been balling
the whole year is there any chance that
Dee Ford is having a Brandon Graham like
career where the first four years it's a
little bit underwhelming yeah but then
they start hitting their stride and Dee
Ford was one of your favorite pass
rushers coming out of that dress he
hasn't been healthy his first three
years he hit six for 250 he's got like
the same measurables as Vaughn mill he
can fly you know and you so started like
now yes he's been like that all year
long but here he is again it's been
battling the groin injury the last two
weeks little things like that it's
always something nagging with him that's
really kind of hurt his trajectory there
and you got naughty starting at DT now
Nadia DT is great okay and that was the
one thing I noticed early like they were
not you want to keep going through them
yeah I'm just gonna talk about Maddie
but Nadi yeah they need big people like
naughty when the one thing they did
early that I liked with Kansas City is D
Ford might have been in the game but the
other three D lineman in the game were
naughty Chris Jones and Alan Bailey
right so they had other big people yeah
which is the right approach just in case
Jacksonville tries to get in the shotgun
and spread you out and then run it with
TJ Yeldon it's those things you have to
be where did they cover the short
crossers and all that that we always ask
yes they did
there was a there was one or two plays
where they got caught in man-to-man and
and the shore crossers were dialed up
one of them was a DD Westbrook where he
caught it and ran up the field for a
whole bunch of yards but for the most
part you know they tried to not let the
fade opportunities be there a whole lot
and when they were Jacksonville threw
him you saw a DJ charcoal was right yeah
so when they were there they did it but
for the most part yes they used they're
kind of underneath umbrella coverage a
three deep sown three deep zone kind of
was kind of a Seattle pres baelish and
then I want to say it was like an 11
funnel almost where they used two or
three guys to funnel the two guys inside
and you know which whatever way they go
that outside guy will take those two the
completions came against man for the
most part they did yes they did I mean
yeah I would the Chiefs ever run man I
bet they don't they have scant they have
three like nickel corners as their
quarterbacks why would they ever
I agree I'd they don't need to be living
in that coverage they need to be very
careful playing too much man-to-man how
viable are the Chiefs as a true Super
Bowl contender yeah they're real there's
no denying it there's no denying it
doesn't it doesn't matter how bad their
defenses their offense is that special
and they're not afraid to let up big
plays on defense because like we saw two
years ago when they were the number two
seed in the playoffs that year
remember all those defensive touchdowns
and plays they made on the defensive
saraberry had the pick of a two-point
conversion right laughs Marcus Peters
had picked sixes all year long huge one
in Carolina right here so they had all
those kind of that's the kind of players
they have so it's not always sound they
do blow a cover where the players like
who are the guys we don't know about
well the fuller public the fuller kid is
really good at 9:04 right not easy a
rookie he's a rookie at a forest they
did he was a fourth round pick and he's
doing defensive tack TV Ford's been
balling out okay the two middle
linebackers are different this year with
Hitchin and Raglan they're silent for
Buffalo they treated hitchens they stole
from Dow exactly right and other than
that you know oh and Justin Houston is
how's he been he's been good it's never
gonna be the 22 and a half sack we saw
the wire cuz I don't think his knee or
leg is ever gonna quite be the same but
I forgetting stuff at addy Ford it makes
his leg and he's good enough he is good
enough to where he pops five or six
times a game where you go there's Justin
Houston in the backfield
around the quarterback so man that
that's where they could be dangerous
added to the fact they can be dangerous
because they don't have Eric Barry back
and Bob Sutton is not afraid to do
unconventional things and that gives
them an edge to go every now and then oh
the ball did get tipped in the air or
there is a guy drop in this area they
never did this on film and it's pretty
wild that we're like man Jacksonville
Kansas City game of the year and then
the next week Kansas City New England
maybe a preview of the AFC Championship
game I mean
mahomes is going to Denver playing the
Jaguars and then is it in New England
isn't in New England I mean we're
getting to see everything like it I know
there's no more there's nothing more for
him to answer for me
I don't care if he goes up there and
like the only thing he needs to answer
is stop calling him Showtime one I don't
care if that was your childhood nickname
we're gonna call you whatever we want
and Showtime is a corny nickname I don't
like it it was an 80s basketball team
you're better than Showtime well I think
Kelsey's the one that keeps calling on
that so it's not like we need to have a
talk with Kelsey okay he said drop DM
him or something sometimes okay there I
think you did to earn a back page that I
read all your notes all right uh Baker
Mayfield yeah here we were the Browns
have now finished a game in every way
possible they've won a game in
regulation they've lost the game in
regulation they've tied a game they've
won a game in overtime they've lost a
game in overtime you want it the Browns
got it they're two two and one Hugh
Jackson is sitting there go and I am
almost positive that Hugh Jackson when
the field goal went in put up to say
that there were two seconds left on the
clock you saw that too 100% 100% he was
telling his guys to come off the field
give the receiving the sidelines not as
much as I want to Jackson to experience
joy there are so many parts where I go
you just don't deserve well he guards
well he's been scarred he's easy thinks
that somehow the universe has come
around to [ __ ] this up for me somehow
but yeah they were actually in that
laughing about it the announcer
something
they were okay I was watching I was
utilize the games over like and then
they were fine like the Browns are
finally coming onto the veal yeah for
the Browns to beat the Ravens a team at
the last 20 games they've beaten two
times yeah is a huge win to do it in a
fashion where it was second and 21 and
overtime on their own five Baker runs
for 13 outrunning terrell suggs
yeah a guy who has haunted Browns
quarterbacks for like a decade and then
on the next play to be under their
duress and to backup and to throw a
perfect crosser to Derrick Willie's yeah
whoo I didn't even know existed and for
him to pick up 39 yards to set up the
the the what eventually would be the
game-winning field goal I came away
going man that's Baker's the dude yeah
you watch the film big statement how was
the first big test for Baker against the
best defense he's faced this year
Baker's the dude there's no other way
around it they won the game the one of
the reasons they won the game was
because their quarterback was better I
mean that's their so there's no other
way to say it I mean when there was
plays there to be had he strikes I mean
that's what's big that's awesome about
Baker it's like we always talk about our
conversation of what was there to be had
what did you leave on the field Baker
doesn't leave crap on the field
Baker sees a hole and he goes I'm firing
I'm gonna throw it don't the heater give
him the heater rhaegar yeah and he fires
it was decision makings really good his
decision-making is it's it's off the
charts for the most part I mean
off-the-charts his interception early on
hold on let me think it goes deflected
it was the it was the fact that he got
screwed he got screwed the receiver
turned up Higgins return turned up the
field he was coming on the crosser and
Baker kind of had a move out of the
pocket and it wasn't totally Higgins
fall I think he thought oh he's in a
scramble let me make myself available
but Baker didn't actually leave the
pocket he kind of just shuffled a little
and he was gonna throw him on the under
out and he turned up just as he was
throwing it was I I want to apologize I
was wrong I said that the Browns could
have taken sake one at
one and like another quarterback at four
Baker one and ward at four both look
good both look good I mean well yeah
Ward was really good too
but keep going on but yeah Baker is he
the best quarterback in this draft can
we say that me five weeks for now yes
for sure okay yes I don't think there's
any denying it's hard to even tell what
Rosen and Allen are I mean with their
supporting cast it's just gonna be like
I said like Rosen had a few strikes on
so yes no help so that's just like
Allen's
touchdown run in the beginning of the
game is freak show that was like him and
Cam Newton right that's exactly right so
you know I don't know what kind of feel
we'll have for them this year but the
one thing we are gonna know but this
year's over his Baker Mayfield is really
good like I'm not gonna say oh he's
definitely gonna be the best one five
years from now I know there's still a
lot of football but either way they made
the right choice this guy is the real
deal he's better than I thought he
doesn't play a small doing that's better
than what you I think that he what
scared didn't bring up his hide a lot
yeah what scared me was the Georgia game
the second half last year remember I
said that pocket collapsed and I thought
man Baker LaVon was chasing one throw
the ball in the pocket but he's learned
already in the NFL that that's that's
part of the game and him just sliding
moving eyes down in the field and then
the quality of throws that he make are
just they're phenomenal other thing too
that you have to talk about with
Cleveland right Cleveland towlines real
and that's what I was gonna say you
wrote three things here in a row that I
think are being forgotten yeah you wrote
Baker in the pocket and is throwing our
phenomenal yeah Browns interior three
offensive linemen are phenomenal
remember ready net twice go ahead and
then you wrote baker's big plays and
taking it care of the ball won this game
they won the game I mean because but
there he is the rookie that came to the
best ou line he definitely came to the
bet I mean JC Treader Joel Ben Tonio and
Zeidler on the inside I put that up
against any three in football I'm not
saying they're the best but they would
belong in a conversation their issues
are tackle play like when you see him
get pressure it's more likely than not
you know the kid Harrison 69 is a rookie
is having to play left tackle yeah
it's Tollhouse he'd been doing he's good
he has a little bit of an anchor problem
he needs to just become get a little
more ass a little more of a Duncan dunk
but he'll get there but yes their own
line you do have to worry about them
with the interior run game and hide and
chub who are very good
yeah and then Haley puts together a good
game plan every week anything else about
the Browns offense and they're like the
Ravens defense play well Ravens even has
played very well they really did they
were all over only scored 12 I know they
were all over a lot of stuff and they
were in really I on Jimmy Smith look
good he didn't play a ton but when he
did play I said damn Jimmy's running
better than I thought tall was last year
before he was healthy excuse me brother
that was but yes I I'm just gonna sounds
like most of your issues are with the
Ravens offense yes
the Ravens go off with Crabtree the
offensive line Flacco where he was I
mean the Ravens defense played good
enough them win that game and it will
only be a Baker guy that can make that
game happen like a guy that can move and
make great throws on the run and do that
that could win that type of game there
yesterday and he did that Ravens offense
what will happen first where is this the
Browns defense being really really good
the Browns defense is really good but I
would I would challenge that the Ravens
I don't know if they had a game plan
yesterday it was all the old let's spin
the rolodex and just pick a play and I
don't we don't really have a plan we're
just gonna call plays today I mean I
first a hoarding wag staple right how do
you run the ball the way they've run the
ball especially like coming off last
week dominating Pittsburgh in the run
game clay even got dominated in the run
game by the Oakland Raiders and they
came out and ran the ball eight freakin
times in the first half I just don't
understand what's the point of having
Marshall Yonder and Ronnie Stanley and
Alex Lewis and all these big guys if
you're not gonna like just stay patient
with the run a little bit this is this
is the Cleveland Browns they're like
twenty second and defense and run
defense and football like when did it
say like damn we can't go against that
bunch we gotta throw it 60 times a Joe
Flacco and then to have an underwhelming
bullcrap passing attack for it I mean
repeat concepts nothing interesting
Crabtree dropping the ball Joe making
some bullcrap
throws yeah you know they Daguerre the
game was there for them to control it
and win it if they wanted to hmm but
interception down in a red zone on the
one-yard line one on the why are you
throwing I don't know why are you
throwing it you have the biggest
offensive line in football why well I
don't even understand it just Jab Jab
Joanne there right do anything put a
little more Jackson on the shotgun and
just have three tight ends in and say
screw you Browns you're not gonna stop
us I I just I didn't understand the plan
of attack and then the lack of patience
with the run game was mind blowing to me
and he of Collins and Jeff aureus Allen
right not a bad one too I mean pass
protection was fine there was a few
times where they exposed them through
blitz and they're everything like that
Denzel Ward was awesome he's John Brown
John Brown's gonna have nightmares about
Denzel Ward because you know John
Brown's one of those small fast guys
right but he's not like super fat you
know Tyree kill Antonio Marez before the
injury maybe before the injury yes it
was smoke but this is the bad matchup
for him because denzel's got a little
more size and then that kind of speed to
just go yeah
I'm a little bigger than you and
stronger than you know and I'm faster
straightaway than you know and that was
a bad combo for John Wow yeah he
couldn't denzel's been another guy he's
just he's he's out I still don't think
he was 25 spots better than the other
corners in the draft yes
but he's been really good Cleveland
Browns are they what are they I mean we
know what Cleveland is no I do not I
have no idea no III think you do
Cleveland's a good football team that's
not going anywhere
now that Baker Mayfield is a quarterback
their defense is going to be they have
enough athletes and scheme to be
annoying for any offense
you're not gonna overpower them on
either side of the ball on a consistent
basis and they have playmakers and and
and a scheme on offense to go with that
like oh they got the Chargers this
weekend at home like damn that game is
gonna go down to the wire there's no
doubt there they got the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers the week after that damn they
could be Tampa we know that yeah so
they're they're gonna be in the thick of
this and they're
learning how to win and I would just say
that your that story about Baker against
the Raiders where they were gonna Haley
was gonna yell at the wide receivers and
Baker goes I got it
yeah and goes over there and brings the
receivers together and talks to all them
in Haley's like okay all right there you
go
Browns defense how's your boy Myles
Garrett doing very good he didn't like
kill it yesterday they got some other
guys that are also just yeah who rising
coolly yeah the kid Coco Lee tempo I
don't know if I'm saying it right 93 to
have on Coley every week pops like I
just go Alba Dewey Hogg a GU nabi yes
kid from North Carolina A&T yes there's
a really good job you know they're more
like 93 is a run stopper ogen job E is
more of like a a little bit smaller run
stopper but creates havoc Emmanuel água
is a man on the outside yeah
what about their linebacker linebackers
are good man what about the Ravens what
are they
the Ravens I don't know what their
offense is Larry Hogan Jobi Hogan Joby
it's just a little all over the place
the race Marty morning wig is which is
really funny because I used to get upset
with Andy abandoning the run and well
they were together for those four or
five years and now I think it's Marty
morning wags because Joe Flacco's should
never be attempting that many pros I
don't get I don't need to you don't know
what they are offense or defense no and
they don't even defense no defense
they're fine but they're often yes their
difference ain't going anywhere their
defense was phenomenal yesterday
it really was I have no qualms with
their defense at all there's no there's
no weakness to their defense other than
that maybe they don't have a great pass
rusher it's my only thing Eagles offense
where are we oh did you read yet I have
not Philadelphia fans are going Carson
Wentz is back
we're not even we're averaging like 21
points a game we can't score against
Minnesota they turn down a field goal
which comes back to bite them they ended
up punting but you know time for the
field goal there first of all yeah like
why why we
throwing the 20-yard hole shot to Alshon
Jeffrey down the middle
let's just get six yards which he had to
his left Carson's being there's a few
plays where I want to go Carson's being
a little that's a good place house
Carson when Carson's been really good he
does not have a lot of help
you guys aren't past protecting well
you've got nobody to be scared of in the
past game other than Al Shean and it's
not like people are scared of his defeat
it's just his size and they worry about
that so but Carson's being a little um
you know I don't want to say selfish
he's asking for too much sometimes like
what you know what was the big throw we
threw down to was that Gibson the 48
yard pass what a freaking cat scratch
what a catch but at me now Sean Jeffery
was open wide open in the middle of the
field for 20 yards just throw to him
nobody's covered him I mean nobody it
was like a few instances like that even
the out Sean Jeffery other play that hey
it was still a phenomenal throw and I'm
but he had the under out for 10 yard
gain and you're gonna kick the field was
a good throw it out it was a great drop
but but I just think that to me goes
into coaching more than Carson Wentz
like the coach has to say hey if we got
our concept side here get the concept I
want to get us in field goal position
because then when you go down 23
whatever motive in 20 at that point or
23 17 you would had a chance to still
win the game on the last Drive of the
game right mmm so of course it's been
okay what about the offensive line the
pass protection the [ __ ] I was like the
strength for the team I know
I mean Lane Johnson it's every game it's
four or five plays I know I don't know
what he's he's he's getting into a
little bit of his you know what I always
say the bucket step he's not doing that
all the time he's kind of getting his
hour old basketball he's guarding
somebody in basketball a few times a
game where he just opens up to the the
pass rusher and now the pass rusher has
a two-way go on I'm and as soon as he
leans the wrong way he's at a
disadvantage so he's been an issue Jason
Peters hasn't been the lockdown guy he's
always been through his career and then
when he comes out for a few plays vitai
gets thrown into a bad spot too and it
usually takes him a series to kind of
get going I read an article that said
vitai is great when he knows he's the
starter going into it I wouldn't believe
that when he comes in halfway through
which is the issue with Peters
because Peters can have to leave the
game at any moment me he missed I to
Ceres vitai is not good at that I mean
it's hard to be good at that I can tell
you just from being a backup quarterback
when I had a come on the freakin game
and go Dan everybody else is in like
full froth mode here and but but Sims
when I play Madden
yeah there's no drama in fact they're
fresher right it's so no they're about
Kelsey what about Brandon Brooks
Brandon books is that that's the thing
they're missing right now I mean just
run behind them like Brooks is still a
road grader in the run game your run
game is there they have to be more
patient with it it was there yesterday
but a Jaya's frustrating of course he
fumbled and your running backs yes they
don't give smallwood enough touches to
me the agile thing I think they need to
just put him on the shelf for a while
let his knee totally heal but for him to
keep coming out there for a week and
then always banged up we don't know he's
questionable return and then he does
come back in and it's just not helping
your team at all the call before the
half is endorsing to the NFL oh it's a
game-changing moment I mean first of all
your defense was phenomenal that led to
the feeling touch that led to the
Thielen touchdown I mean they're gonna
be in third and 14 and maybe get a field
goal so there is your team led up 23
points when I really want to say no
they'll up 13 because there was an
interception return for a touchdown
I was all Joseph's right so that's an 16
I have a hard time thinking the
Minnesota was gonna convert a third and
14 in the way your defense is playing
I mean Minnesota didn't really do [ __ ]
the whole day they did have one deep
pass to Thielen yeah and I think it was
exactly what you just ranted about it
was a blitz and it was Jalen Mills so it
was a blur wasn't blitz you were right
it was a blitz but you didn't need to be
a blitz again is Fletcher Cox got there
in 2.4 seconds it's pressure is not an
issue with your team when they just send
their front four that's when you're at
your best and your front four gets there
just as quickly
when there's no blitz as there is when
there is a blitz it doesn't matter
hey I'm not saying they don't never
blitz ever again in the history but they
need to be a once in a while sporadic
type thing and they were like that in
this game left go
Schwartz he's been listening he listens
isms and left go why because he stopped
blitzing I don't know he stopped
blitzing him he did not blitz much in
the game except that one time a blitz
the one time where you got him backed up
and you're gonna go huh our best player
versus their worst player huh I'll throw
it up I mean yeah and Jalen Mills they
need to move him into the slot and is
our man okay Sydney Jones I don't know
cuz he do we know that it was on the
ground for a while I know I think he
came back in though I don't know they
moved Avante Maddox to safety how did he
do he did good I like it I mean at least
it's speed out there and I do think
Sydney Jones needs to go on the outside
and they need to move Jalen Mills to the
slot Minnesota how do they look
Minnesota's offense is nothing special I
mean I don't know what else to say they
really didn't do crap in the game other
than cousins made a few great throws
like that one I like the I felt like the
Eagles did blitz a lot towards the end
and that's why I kept seeing Rudolph
slippin out and dig slippin yeah there
was a few here and there what's crazy
sometimes is you guys don't even blitz
and you got eight men down by the line
of scrimmage and you believe Jalen Mills
one on one too and I want to be what's
what's the point like I just don't get
it they have to protect that matchup
Kirk Cousins any time he got one-on-one
pressure it was wears Jalen Mills I'm
throwing to that guy really and whether
it was the you know the first drive do
you remember the little he got
tremendous pressure you guys don't blitz
he throws like a post corner route on
the first drive yet throws it way before
it the guy's out of his break but he
knows this Jalen Mills on Stefon Diggs
he's gonna put it out there for Stefan
cuz Stefan's gonna go get it before
Jalen does are the Vikings gonna turn
this around I don't I don't I'm not sure
about that why I just don't I don't
think the defense is quite as it's not
gonna be as dominant as last year I
don't see it ever sent us out
indefinitely we have no idea right
coming back
and I do think that people have caught
on to their scheme a little bit on the
defensive side of the football and I
think their offense is a different
animal this year I don't think they can
run the ball consistently and I don't
I'm not gonna put John D Flippo and
schirmer's class quite yet as an
offensive game designer Eagles how much
chaos are they in I I'm okay the Eagles
are okay I I'm so calm about the Eagles
that it's annoying my friends that are
Eagles fans cuz they're going it all
comes down we got the Giants on Thursday
then Caroline and then we're going to
London and I'm like I don't see East I
mean yeah you might be nine and seven my
she didn't lose us to the Saints tonight
they all lost who cares I know I know
no you were the better you were the
better team on the field yesterday I
think that's that's what a Philly fan
can take away from it to go when I
watched the film back they said no
Philly was the better team they had a
few mistakes here and there they have to
stay more patient with the run game they
got to help Carson once out it's just
too hard it's too much it's it's all him
Wow
what Sydney Jones no jje torn ACL placed
on IR there you go wow that just
happened a.m. so what does that mean
what's your reaction I don't think it's
a big deal so for the way he's so jje
tearing his ACL you're going not a big
deal long no I don't I don't his knee is
an issue there's a reason the Dolphins
traded in him and that's why they traded
him and you guys are desperate and
probably gave up a little too much
because you were in a super multi award
that's I got a ring exactly right I'm
not mad at I think you'd run against
Denver felt really good what happen Yeah
right and a lot of great moments just
last year but yeah I don't think this is
a the way he's been playing and running
the ball the last few weeks I don't
think this is a huge loss like I said
Wendell small ones better than him right
so this is a Wendell Smallwood Corey
Clement team when he gets back I think
so do you think they need to make a move
yeah I know I just have a hard time
seeing that happening but that would be
amazing
so as an Eagles fan you see the jje news
and you don't get too worried I wouldn't
be worried
I feel like Doug Peterson has to have
more but I feel like I'm about to say
the [ __ ] I used to say last year and the
before this more between the tackles
runs okay
use your size and physicality every time
they run the ball between the tackles I
go dim the other D line there's no
that's like a Jacksonville run I go
there's no hole but the guy just ran
four yards from with no hole because
they just mash everybody back yeah
so that play-action screens again I have
more of that have not seen a script for
a what's that I mean they got to have
more of it it's Adam against Tampa yeah
it's just too it's too much on carson
wentz right now to hang in there make it
tight throw and it's not working
all right so Wednesday we're gonna dive
in I really want you all for rookie
quarterbacks one yeah so I want to know
you know is Sam dharna learning the deep
ball right how did Josh Allen upset all
right yeah I'm very excited to watch I
had no feel for that Tennessee Buffalo
game my all other than I just kept
looking at it and going Shawn McDermott
yeah I like deserves to be in the coach
of the year conversation I don't give a
[ __ ] what his record is this is what he
did last year I know it's even better
than last year cuz he's got less he's
got way less I'm telling you in like
three years Shawn McDermott's could be
playing with popsicle sticks and he's
still gonna be holding people to 12
points at home it really is crazy it's
unbelievable and credit to you for the
call on that one man man yeah I just
think when you quickly look at all the
games like Pittsburgh Atlanta was kind
of what we saw today and I didn't score
yeah
Atlanta's defense is done done like I
told you done done giants Carolina
I mean Philly Pittsburgh tried to let
them hang around the game I mean been
through about the dumb interception at
one point yes but yet they're there
they're in deep crap new Giants Carolina
to come back in that game and then
there's been that the 63 yarder on
Sunday it was only the sixth time in NFL
history that a kick has been 63 yards or
longer I didn't think there was any
chance he was hitting that it went
through that was nuts but it's amazing I
mean Carolina Giants uh Carolina's a
good squad but they are Cam Newton
sometimes kind of gets unhinged and yeah
he missed a few throws certainly early
on in the game I always feel like that's
the way with him when they have a week
off or they first start in the start of
the regular season like he gets that
front shoulder tilted up too much and he
gets his real just muscular jerky motion
and
Liuzza's he was a little too I'll tell
DJ mores got the juice as he Kurtis
Samuel made right I love a play
yeah I'm looking going man that's some
good weapons right here and they're
getting Thomas Davis back next week so
look out for Carolina Green Bay Detroit
Detroit punts it down to the one and
it's a fumble they get the ball in the
one they score a touchdown and then it's
a it's a rods looking good they missed a
field goal 60 yard pass to gala day
Detroit's up 14 nothing and and then
every time Green May went down they
missed a field goal next thing you know
24 nothing and I still thought Rodgers
was gonna win that frickin game yeah
every time I looked up Rogers was
driving down it would end with a missed
field goal where he get tackled for a
fumble but they're still down at one
point like 24 to 18 yeah 12 or 16 yeah
24 or 14 right but I'm with you I I'll
say this early on in the game the one
thing that jumped out to me and is
another one it looked like Detroit was
all over Green Bay I'm Trisha Bella
cherry I mean I think Patricia and
Belichick could teach that that if they
switched like coaches Patricia and
Belichick could have gone into Green Bay
this week and acted like they were
McCarthy and Joe Philbin and being like
here's the offense guys when this guy
does those look like they could teach
that offense and that's what it looked
like to me early on and the only other
game that I think you if you saw it
would explain it dolphins up 17 nothing
and two defensive lineman return
touchdowns for the Bengals and they end
up losing that game 27 to 17 yeah Ryan
Tannehill is not a kind of guy that you
go at the end of the game we need you to
- now get points no no he's right he's
not he's just not a not a gifted enough
thrower that way the the Dolphins
offense is just disappointing I think
right right now lacks creativity can't
seem to find any big plays okay yeah
they scored they scored 17 points yes
tell them or a punt return exactly right
you can grant we also have to say with
the Giants and I'll be excited to what I
mean they had a punt the Carolina turn
into a touchdown
exactly right and damsei qualm Berkeley
and Odell Beckham jr. are good holy crap
I mean it just shows you that when you
utilize them it can it changes the whole
game the team and gentlemen traded Odell
Mather League
it's a qualm have we heard anything more
about his name
he did land a little weird but did he
play after that no because that was the
I was down and kick the field goal that
we scored a win that was the score to
win which I mean that was phenomenal I
also want to say this yeah the Giants
Panthers game had the worst penalty of
the weekend we can talk about Michael
Bennett bringing him down there's a lot
of questionable calls there was one on
TJ watt where he liked Lions come on and
that was a line a passer but the worst
call the weekend I saw this one Landon
Collins one of the safeties douve to
intercept the pass had his hands on the
ball and as he dove his head hit the
receivers head and they called him for
hitting at defenseless right it wasn't
Landon Collins I think it was the 35 kid
but but if you get your hands on the
ball and you're diving to catch it
you're not trying to hit the guy in the
head there that was the worst call
Landon Collins came out and said it's
some of these penalties men they're
ridiculous yes but you'll see one did
what's annoying is you'll see one game
where every penalties called to the
letter of the law and then I watch
another game and go there is no law out
here in this game it's just the Wild
West or letting them do whatever they
want Shawn Watson and dak Prescott were
taking helmets like JJ Watt put his
helmet into dak Prescott sternum and on
the last interception for deshaun Watson
before they Dallas trove down at the
field goal deshaun Watson went back and
DeMarcus Lawrence another guy like raked
his face and hit him like and then
landed on him and they didn't call
anything yeah athletic quarterbacks and
I'm not even making a black-white thing
bigger quarterbacks like Carson Wentz
doesn't get a lot of calls either no the
ones that the refs think that can handle
it don't get calls man Kirk Cousins gets
a lot of calls yeah right and I bet you
Alex Smith and Drew Brees can lion that
lion yeah like it's almost better if
you're a quarterback is not athletic
looking III do think there's some truth
to that
I do like Big Ben doesn't get a lot of
calls either away I know this damn
number Ford's got to protect themselves
deshaun Watson that was ridiculously
Shaun Watson got hit five or six times
and props to Jaylon Smith for having the
speed
to beat him down the sidelines but
deshaun Watson had four plays at the
goal line rollin he's dead I mean just
he can't do that he's gonna separate his
shoulder he's gonna break a collarbone
like it just fun to watch i-it's amazing
to watch the last night he looked really
good again I mean I think we're getting
back to seeing DeSean from last year so
it means just gonna get hurt in three
weeks I hope that I hope not to Monday
night we are both picking Washington to
cover are you picking New Orleans to win
yeah I think I picked them like 3128
something like that yeah did you get any
of your predictions completely right I
mean I don't know I'm really
disappointed my picks altogether I don't
even know it's I have to reevaluate how
I'm picking this games I've got an issue
with my game picking why cuz I'm just um
you know me I'm so swamped with trying
to catch up to watch all the games I
just feel like when Wednesday night
comes I'm like huh whoo I made it
let me watch a ton of film in three days
and we really broke it down wait who's
playing who tomorrow and what do I got a
pickup and I just I'm pissed off of
myself with some of my picks I
accomplished something Sunday that has
been a dream of mine and it really is
hard to even understand
I went ten and four against the spread
Thursday and Sunday which any better
would say that's incredible incredible
it's incredible incredible oh and for
all my locks tenha know with all my
other picks so my mentions are awful I
know they're I mean I'm being called I'm
a newborn baby could touch a screen and
pick better games than you like the
insults that I'm getting it give
everyone always says I should have your
job that's always one but ten and oh oh
and four locks locks my locks Ravens
minus three which I thought they were
gonna get in overtime yeah and they
didn't get at least him give me a push
Rams minus seven which they they were
scorned their defense couldn't stop
anything right Jacksonville plus three
that was just bad that was just bad the
other two I have our excuses for and
then um I mean I could just pull them up
Oakland no pit no I wanted to pick pit
oh I got every other one right Green Bay
Detroit Miami Cincinnati John I already
said Jacksonville Tennessee Buffalo see
you know England India and in Alice I
would have gotten that one
it was Carolina minus seven oh man they
had it too at it you're right this sucks
hey I don't listen I think what I'm
gonna do next week for the betting show
is pick all my games pick four locks and
then I'm just gonna pick four other
games
I'm just gonna pick four other games as
my locks I'm gonna these are ones I'm
most confident about and be like just
pick four random ones right he's in the
weeds all right that's it guys we're
gonna do more deep dives on Wednesday
thank you as always for Sims peace out
homies vendrick would say good evening
and the lef koe man says you need to
watch the show Wednesday night - Rico
and is becoming a Jewish man yes holla
holla holla holla holla I'll talk to you
then
Oy Vey Oy Vey he alerts what away babies
you